hey this is super interesting uh cnn did
an analysis of the trump rioters who
have been arrested
and found that many of these trump
rioters who were rioting because they
believe
the will of the people was not done and
that somehow joe biden is going to be
president even though donald trump
really won the election
a lot of those trump rioters didn't even
vote
this may not be surprised to many of you
cnn obtained voting records for more
than 80 of the initial arrestees
the majority did vote in the
presidential election
um but a bunch of them uh are not even
registered to vote
there are a whole bunch of people who
either aren't registered or did not vote
in the 2020 election and this is
interesting for for a number of
different
reasons first of all had they voted
they may not have felt the need to storm
the capital
because donald trump might actually have
won it'll if a lot of these
riotous insurrectionists had voted now i
know it's only a few thousand people who
went to dc
i'm including in that people just
generally supportive of the riotous
insurrection
uh what is very clear and and
unfortunately
unfortunate in terms of what it means
about american culture and society
is that conspiracy theories are far more
compelling than simply going out and
voting and participating in the
democratic system that we claim to have
they didn't vote but they're sure that
donald trump must
have won because hold on a second even
they couldn't be bothered to vote
and that is really something that should
cause some self-reflection if you are
saying
i am sure trump won because clearly more
people must have voted for him but wait
a second
i didn't even vote if i didn't vote
there's probably lots of people who
preferred trump who didn't vote
that moment of self-reflection seems to
never come
and before you know it they're in
washington d.c breaking windows and
getting into the capitol and messing
with
nancy pelosi's desk or whatever they
were doing imagine that
the concept of stop the steal of our
votes
when we didn't even vote stop stealing
our votes
i mean other people like i didn't vote
okay yeah but i'm talking about other
people
it's an incredible situation and uh many
may even have stayed home because donald
trump said it was rigged which again
raises the idea of whether trump himself
by saying it's rigged don't vote early
don't vote by mail or do vote by mail
depending on the state but not
unsolicited ballots
all of that stuff may also have held
down
turnout in a way that was damaging to
donald trump now i have to be very real
with you guys
with how close it was it's probably a
good thing that a lot of these people
didn't vote
trump really might have won if a lot of
these people
voted it may have been trump himself who
suppressed turnout
just enough to prevent him from even
winning and that's a really scary
thought
when you think about how close it was
and how it came down to
yeah i know that we talk about a massive
popular vote victory and the same
electoral margin for joe biden than
trump won with in 2016.
but it came down to you know 150 60 70
100
000 votes in a few states much like the
2016 election
now big picture it is not uncommon
that people who complain about
government doing or not doing something
don't even vote that's not new that's
not surprising
in the united states often half the
country doesn't vote
much more than half the country
complains but often half the country
doesn't vote in
this particular election it was about 35
40
of the country that didn't vote it's an
ideology of
memes conspiracy theories and sharing
fake news on facebook
that often doesn't actually include
voting
they are more loyal to violence and lies
than they are to the just basic
democratic systems that we have in the
united states
and that's a really difficult thing to
change when we talk about deprogramming
i'm going to have more to say about this
maybe tomorrow or thursday when we talk
about
deprogramming we have to understand that
this culture runs really deep
someone who is committed to
sharing fake news but can't be bothered
to vote
it goes beyond just convincing them that
their ideas are wrong it goes very very
much beyond that
let's take a quick break make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on
instagram at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious fruit drink powder that you
mix
into water for rehydration and they're
giving you
25 off your first order it's made with
four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a b
c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video